speaking of energy you were saying that
um
in some sense things have gotten a
little bit easier in that now you have a
tremendous body of work and then
some
deals or potential things have come from
it and people are interested can you
touch on that so yeah and one of the
exciting things about right now is as
i've distributed
made and distributed multiple films back
to back i'm finally starting to feel
that sense of like a long-term
investment that's really you know paying
off um
not just in terms of money because it's
not paying off with a lot of money but
it's paying off with just enough money
to sustain
but where it's starting to really pay
off is that i think people are
seeing that i get films made and i get
them out and do relatively well with
distribution and so people have started
to to knock on my door which is sort of
a new you know a new a new thing and
it's pretty exciting i've had you know
out i've had you know one guy that's
been emailing me multiple times and
calling me like persistently to try to
get a meeting uh i've had uh somebody
reach out to me who saw ride the divide
um an la uh
an latv director who has a concept for a
tv series and he's uh you know he's got
legit connections and contacts and and
some great actors um that he's he's
worked with and also got committed to be
part of the series and it's a cycling
series ultimately so he's interested in
sort of fusing a documentary style with
um sort of his narrative approach and
the you know the old narrative approach
to making a tv deal so it's kind of a
cool period of time where it's like i
can sense things are shifting you know i
can sense that there's you know it's one
of those deals where it hasn't quite
fully opened up yet but it's nice to to
to feel that you know if you really stay
committed you make films and you're
really focused on
on something that eventually you will
get um people seeking you out you know
and and talking to you and i mean in the
instance of this potential tv series i
know it's it's like all my other
projects and all my other things i don't
get too excited because a lot of things
a lot of these things don't pan out and
that's something you
you sort of learn to
to to do over the years is you just you
can't get overly excited you have to
take you know take everything with a
grain of salt and take your time on it
and make sure you have multiple ideas
you know in the hopper and if
something's failing and not working get
rid of it move on you know and i think
um i think when you can kind of figure
out that right sort of um sort of
assortment of things and energy and
and people start knocking on your doors
that's that's ideally when you know when
you can kind of say okay i've done all
this for a reason you know like it's
actually going to potentially pay off so
i'm not trying to hopefully i'm not
jinxing myself right now
but i do feel like you know we're i'm
kind of at that turning point in the
career where some things can happen in
fact i think i watched one of your
um interviews where someone said 12
years overnight success i'm like shoot
i'm that almost 10 years now so that
means i've got two more years and then
i'll uh i'll get to be the overnight
success so i'm waiting waiting for that
day it's funny because i remember the
past it used to be like seven years or
something and like now i'll send it to
12 years but
whatever i guess we're here
you